[Applause]
the count promised many more for the
nationalist party committed to a united
ireland and predicted by opinion polls
to beat their pro-british unionist
rivals for the first time in a hundred
years
i'm a lifelong republican and we are a
republican party
to have united island we also have to
show
that we deal with people's issues as
they go so these things are not
separated or inseparable
shin feins campaign focused on bread and
butter issues like the cost of living
crisis health and housing as precursors
to irish reunification
the unionist vote on the other hand was
split with the largest party the
democratic unionists threatening to
boycott the stormont assembly because of
post-brexit border arrangements that
they say undermine the very union they
exist to defend the known iron protocol
is a key issue for us at this moment in
time and we need to get
resolution of that issue because trade
barrier has been created within a
country between great britain and
northern ireland
and we need to move that trade barrier
and get rid of that and ensure that the
military protocol is dealt with once and
for all
which raises the possibility of a
full-blown political crisis after this
election paralysis deadlock arising out
of the two-party power sharing system
under the good friday peace agreement
and not for the first time
that's why growing numbers of voters
have chosen a third way among the
biggest winners in this election the
cross community center ground alliance
party northern ireland isn't just a
place where it's nationalists and
unionists northern ireland is a place
that is diverse
and this vote for alliance is showing
that there are more people who
are satisfied with being a bit of both
and also being northern irish
it's further evidence of potentially
seismic shifts in the political
landscape i think what you put it down
to is first of all uh post-brexit
tiredness actually with what has
happened since it's become very green
and orange i think you put it down to a
new younger electorate who no longer are
interested in these things and i think
you put it down to the fact that for a
number of years we've hardly had any
government and there's a real wish for a
large part of this population to get on
was actually getting stuff addressed
which isn't just constitutional
all of which sets up a fertile
conversation about the future in
northern ireland one far less tethered
to the sectarian constraints of the past
jonah hull al jazeera belfast